voilà le baça le bassin d'eau vive qui a
été mise en eau en fait qui a été mise
en å donc le comme je disais en fait cet
équipement il à être l'histoire puisque
les premières intentions ces années 70
pour vous dire comment ça fonctionne
donc on a quatre rivières au total donc
une rivière de compétition qui sera la
rivière olympique en slalom pour aller
vite c'est la discipline de tony
estanguet bobcat rivière en fait elle
tourne dans ce sens elle est alimentée
par l'eau du lac au conte à un canal
d'amenée qui est ici qui passe sous le
bâtiment qui vient en fait alimenté
cette vaste et avec un système de pompe
donc on a cinq pompes qui font chacune
une tonne donc cédé des grosses machines
comme des pompes de relevage qui
viennent un mélo ici et qui projet clos
donc on est on peut tourner globalement
entre 8 et 14 mètres cubes seconde
souffle et rivières donc la rivière de
compétition on a une deuxième rivière
aux eaux vives qui aiment rivière
d'entraînement là bas où il ya quatre
pompes où on peut fonctionner à plus bas
régime jusqu'à 10 mètres cubes seconde
et on a une rivière en fait on
appellerait dire paysagère qui serpente
que vous la voyez là-bas qui va
quasiment jusqu'à la marne qui permet en
fait de mettre le site en relation avec
la mare de sang est en contact pour des
questions environnementales
et qui sera dédiée à l'initiation à la
pratique
au total ce à peu près 800 m de rivière
artificielle vous avez deux mille places
en fait de mille places de gradins
paysage est derrière vous pendant les
jeux il ses 15000 places à peu près en
plus et c'est 15000 places après sur la
partie avirons
sachant que sur une semaine sur les deux
semaines on aura deux disciplines le
repreneur voilà un système d'éclairage
qui permet la pratique aussi de lui
[Musique]
voilà pour le stade d'eaux vives donc ce
stade d'eaux vives bien sûr j'ai dit
sport-loisir pan de compétition à savoir
que en pratique loisir sur cette île de
loisirs donc on aura du rafting de
l'hydrospeed et puis à toutes les
disciplines dites
qui pourrait imaginer qu'ils permettent
en fait aussi d'équilibrer le modèle
économique puisque sur ce site on a des
sportifs de haut niveau qui n'a entraîné
mais aussi du grand public est long ça
participe aussi de l' équilibre
économique et donc le grand public va
participer à on a l'un des va et on va
éviter tomber dans le chauvinisme et on
va dire l'un des trois plus beaux sites
trois plus gros sites de kayak au monde
certains disent qu'on a aussi le plus
grand site de pratique du kayak au monde
avec le lac la marne et puis là le
bassin d'eau vive
en tout cas on a vraiment à un déclin d
un équipement fait exceptionnel en fait
pour la discipline canoë kayak qui est
dit mais c'est 15 hectares d'aménagement
paysager pour enfoncer aussi les
qualités environnementales de ce site je
lui ai dit mais je redis c'est un suivi
écologique par un écologue c'est des
espèces protégées ces des oiseaux en
fait toute l'année une faune et une
flore exceptionnelles que des gens qui
viennent se balader
c'est toute la gageure en fait c'est
toute l'ambition en fait de la région
c'est de réussir à conjuguer et affaires
se marier à coexister en fait tous ces
pratiques de la personne qui vient
profiter du jardin public qui vient
faire de la stratégie sportive amateur
et qui vient pratiquer son sport à
niveau de haut niveau et ça jusqu'à
l'organisation des jeux